ouf ça va c'est juste une égratignure
heureusement que je suis vacciné contre
le tétanos ait toute cette trouille
c'est vite arrivé 1 mais bon j'ai quand
même vérifier puis ce sera l'occasion de
reparler des bactéries des virus des
vaccins comment ils fonctionnent parce
que en ce moment on entend des vertes et
des pas mûres
allez une petite piqûre de rappel ça
fera pas de mal
[Musique]
à l'heure où je l'aimé ah le voilà mon
carnet de santé
il faut toujours savoir où on l'arrangé
quand même que je pense à faire mon
rappel un vaccin
c'est une substance qui permet à notre
système immunitaire autrement dit nos
défenses naturelles de s'entraîner à
lutter contre certains microbes et
bactéries ou des virus et les détruire
quand il pénètre dans notre organisme
je vais vous montrer considérons que
l'atelier représente l'organisme les
microbes que ce soit les virus ou les
bactéries sont protégés par une
enveloppe la surface des virus vous le
voyez et parfois recouvertes de
proéminence on parle de spicules pia
celui-ci vous le reconnaissez on ne
parle que de lui
depuis des mois le sar skov 2-1
coronavirus on l'appelle ainsi parce que
toutes ces spicules forme d'une couronne
autour de lui leur enveloppe
que ce soit pour le virus ou les
bactéries sont constitués de protéines
notamment des molécules dont certaines
sont propres à chaque microbes et qu'on
appelle des antigènes geyser présenté en
revanche sur ce virus en rouge où celui
ci est en bleu sur la bactérie des
antigènes propres à chaque microbes et
très bien je note au petit gène ça pique
un peu faudra bien penser à prendre vous
cacher un monsieur jamais dit alors le
microbe pénétrer dans l'organisme par
différentes portes les voies
respiratoires la bouche les muqueuses
tiens ça tombe bien tu ressembles un
virus doivent qui pénètre dans
l'organisme
prenons l'exemple d'un virus une fois
dans l'organisme
ils pénètrent dans les cellules pas
n'importe lesquels chaque virus à sa
cible
certains visent les cellules du système
respiratoire par exemple comment ils
rentre-t-il pour faire simple disons que
chaque virus possède une clé spécifique
et que les cellules visées possède la
serrure une fois dans la cellule
le virus prend le contrôle de cette
cellule il s'y multiplient et parfois
l'a détruite alors évidemment on ne se
laisse pas faire grâce à notre système
immunitaire
on se défend on représente aussi souvent
notre système immunitaire sous la forme
d'une forteresse et d'une armée de
petits soldats
dès que notre système immunitaire
détecte un intrus à virus par exemple
c'est le branle bas de combat
en fait il reconnaît les fameuses
antigènes dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
dès lors toute une cascade de réactions
s'enclenche qui implique les fidèles
soldats du système immunitaire les
globules blancs
certains d'entre eux dispose d'une arme
redoutable
les anticorps il se lie aux antigènes et
permettent aux autres globules blancs de
repérer et d'éliminer le virus
éventuellement les cellules infectées
le bonus c'est qu'une fois le microbe
éliminer une petite population de
cellules immunitaires qui a été activée
par l'intrus est stocké dans les
ganglions lymphatiques sous les
aisselles par exemple ou dans la moelle
osseuse
elle garde en mémoire vous le voyez
l'antigène du microbe qui a été vaincu
résultat si celui ci a l'audace de nous
attaquer à nouveau le système
immunitaire le reconnaît immédiatement
et se met en route beaucoup plus
rapidement et plus efficacement que la
première fois ils naissent alors aucune
chance à l'envahisseur
cette mémoire immunologique peut durer
des années voire toute la vie c'est pour
cette raison que la plupart des
personnes qui attrapent la varicelle
durant leur enfance en son protégé pour
le restant de leurs jours
elle va le sien dans tout ça pour que je
vous fasse une petite piqûre de rappel
j'y viens le problème c'est que notre
système immunitaire a parfois du mal à
faire face ou à se mettre en action
le virus ou la bactérie peuvent faire de
gros dégâts avant d'être stoppé voire ne
pas être stoppée du tout c'est le cas
avec le tétanos la tuberculose ou le sar
skov 2 chez certaines personnes le
principe du vaccin consiste donc à
simuler la première attaque d'un microbe
pour que le système immunitaire
s'entraîne à le combattre
ainsi le jour nous sommes exposés
involontairement cette fois à ce virus
ou cette bactérie
notre système immunitaire réagit au
quart de tour l'astuce est bien sûr que
le vaccin doit servir à créer une
mémoire immunologique mais s'en rendre
malade
on ne peut donc pas vaccinés quelqu'un
en lui injectant le micro-ondes en
pleine forme il a fallu biaiser on lui
injecte à l'heure je vais vous montrer
d'abord il ya ce que l'on appelle les
vaccins atténuer comme ceux mis au point
pour lutter contre les oreillons la
rougeole est la fièvre jaune
ceux ci contiennent un microbe entier
est vivant mais qui a été sélectionnée
vous le voyez parce qu'il n'est pas
assez virulent pour rendre malade
ensuite il y a les microbes inactivé
c'est le cas du vaccin contre la grippe
là le virus est entier mais les
chercheurs l'ont tué en l'exposant par
exemple à des rayons uv ou à la chaleur
certains vaccins ne contiennent que des
morceaux du mille club
certaines protéines par exemple c'est le
cas du vaccin contre le papillomavirus l
avantage de ces vaccins c'est qu'ils
sont sans risque même pour les personnes
ayant un système immunitaire déficient
l'inconvénient c'est que la réponse
immunitaire est souvent un fort et que
la mémoire immunologique dur donc moins
longtemps
c'est pour cette raison que pour
certains vaccins il faut de temps en
temps faire un rappel
histoire de rappeler le microbe au bon
souvenir de nos globules blancs et de se
refaire une santé
la rnm
ils ont dit j'en vois pas moins de route
nationale m mais non à rl acide
ribonucléique m
pour messager cette fois il ne s'agit
plus d'injecter le virus ou une partie
du virus mais la recette pour que nos
propres cellules puisse fabriquer un
morceau de virus allez suivez moi parce
que là on peut vraiment en faire un
fromage
le virus possède sous son enveloppe son
propre adn
on parle parfois de génomes une
succession de gênes il s'agit en fait
d'un programme sur lequel figurent
toutes les instructions qui sont
nécessaires à la fabrication des
différents éléments du virus et de
toutes ces caractéristiques le problème
du virus c'est qu'ils ne possèdent pas
d'outils pour lire et exécuté ce
programme voilà pourquoi il infecte les
cellules humaines qui elles possèdent
leur propre aliens et toute une
machinerie pour exécuter ce programme en
infectant les cellules humaines
le virus va détourner cette machinerie
pour se multiplier
revenons à la rna messagers et bien
c'est la copie d'un petit morceau de
l'adn du virus
un petit morceau qui correspond à un
gène le gène qui code pour la
fabrication de l'antigène ce fameux anti
jeunes qui se trouve à la surface du
virus
celui dont on a parlé au début de cette
vidéo et qui permet au système
immunitaire de reconnaître le virus le
vaccin arn messagers consiste donc à
injecter les instructions pour que nos
cellules se met à produire l'antigène
caractéristiques du virus
une fois dans notre organisme le système
immunitaire va lutter contre lui et
s'entraîner à reconnaître et à combattre
le virus
c'est cette méthode qui est utilisé par
plusieurs laboratoires pour lutter
contre le sar skov de elles datent pas
d'hier les chercheurs travaillent dessus
depuis 30 ans et heureusement il a
seulement fallu trouver le mot
rien de transporter la rn jusqu'aux
cellules là encore comme il n'est pas
présent en entier il ne risque pas de se
reproduire et de nous rendre malade
quant à la rn du vaccin les rapidement
détruit par notre système immunitaire
en quelques jours il n'en reste plus
aucune trace dans notre corps en
revanche la mémoire de notre système
immunitaire est prête et attend
désormais de pied ferme le véritable
virus
bah je sais pas vous mais là je me sens
mieux et je me sentirai encore beaucoup
mieux quand je pourrais lire dans mon
carnet de santé que j'ai été vacciné
contre lacko vite 19 les antigènes eux
j'aime bien quand il tombe et le vaccin
dans tout ça bon je vous fasse une
petite piqûre de rappel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]